[موسيقى]
واشنطن تكشف عن سياسه جديده لمبيعاتها
العسكريه حول العالم والشركات الاوروبيه
تسعى لزياده حصتها من سوق الانفاق الدفاعي
في الشرق الاوسط هذه الملفات وغيرها
نطرحها معكم في حلقه اليوم اهلا بكم في
عسكري
ا شركه بوينج الامريكيه تعلن انهاء عمل خط
انتاج طائرات سوبر هورنيد بحلول عام 2025
الشركه اعلنت انها لن تقبل اي طلبات
امريكيه اخرى بخلاف الطائرات الثمانيه
التي اضافها الكونجرس الى الميزانيه
الماليه للعام الجاري على ان تركز خلال
مشروعتها المستقبليه على المسيرات وكذلك
على طائرات التدريب الرقمي مثل طائره تي 7
اي
ضمن خطتها لاستبدال اسطولها من مقاتلات
هوك البريطانيه ماليزيا تتعاقد مع كوريا
الجنوبيه على شراء 18 طائره من طراز اف اي
50 بعقد تصل قيمته الى قرابه المليار
دولار الطائرات التي من المقرر ان يتم
تسليمها بدءا من عام 2016 يمكنها حمل
اسلحه جو جو وكذلك اسلحه جو ارض دقيقه
التوجيه كما ستشكل طفره لسلاح الجو
الماليزي وتحديدا بعد سحب طائرات مايك 29
السوفيتي من الخدمه في عام 2017
شركه ترون فيوتشر التايوانيه تكشف عن خطه
لانتاج 100 منظومه مضاده لطائرات شهريا من
طراز تيرا دار برو خلال العام الجاري
الخطه التايوانيه تاتي في ظل تصاعد
التهديدات التي تمثلها المسيرات الصغيره
التي تستخدمها الصين في عمليات تجسس
واستطلاع حول الجزيره الرادار لديه القدره
على اكتشاف المسيرات في نطاق يبلغ 5
كمترات كما انه يتميز بوزن خفيف الامر
الذي يمنحه قدره اكبر على التنقل
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
على مدى سنوات كانت هناك شكوى دائمه من
تعامل الولايات المتحده الامريكيه مع
مساله تصدير الاسلحه واشنطن تقول ان هناك
معايير اخلاقيه هي التي تتحكم بهذا الامر
في حين يعتبر البعض ان الولايات المتحده
تتخذ احيانا ملف حقوق الانسان كذريعه
لممارسه نوع من انواع الضغط السياسيه على
عملائها مؤخرا اقرت الحكومه الامريكيه
مجموعه من التعديلات الجديده على قوانين
نقل او بيع الاسلحه التقليديه حول هذه
التعديلات وكذلك انعكاسها على مبيعات
الاسلحه الامريكيه وايضا كيفيه تعامل
الشركات الامريكيه معها معنا من واشنطن
السيده فاجو مراديان رئيس تحرير موقع
الدفاع وطيران اولا سيد مراديان اهلا بك
معنا في عسكريتاريا برايك ما هي اهم
التعديلات التي اقرتها الحكومه الامريكيه
على قانون بيع الاسلحه وما هي اهميه هذه
الاجراءات يسرني
[موسيقى]
معكم في هذا البرنامج من جديد بدايه اود
ان اوضح ان هذا ليس قانونا بل هي سياسه
بيع السلاح التقليديه وهي تمثل الاليه
التي تقوم من خلالها الولايات المتحده
كجزء من الاطار القانوني العام وتحدد درجه
المرونه التي تتمتع بها الاداره الامريكيه
لتقرر صفقات بيع السلاح التقليديه التي
يمكن السماح بها او رفضها بدايه هذه
التعديلات ليست بالضروره الجديده بل هي
تضيف صفه رسميه للمنهج الذي تتبعه اداره
بايدن منذ توليها الرئاسه لتؤكد انها
ستدفع بمساله حقوق الانسان عند اجراء
صفقات لبيع السلاح التقليديه والدوله
الوحيده المعفيه من هذه الاجراءات هي كندا
لكن بالنسبه للدول الاخرى فهناك اعتبارات
لحقوق الانسان لكن هناك عنصرا اخر يتم
اقفاله وهو على نفس القدر من الاهميه ان
هناك محدد اخر وهو طبيعه العلاقه بين
الدوله بالصفقه مع كل من الصين وروسيا وقد
تاخرت هذه السياسه قليلا بسبب الحرب
الاوكرانيه لكن في نهايه الامر فان الاطار
العام الذي تحاول ان تستفيد منه الاداره
هو حقوق الانسان كما يجب الانتباه للصيغه
المستخدمه التي تقول انه من المرجح
الموافقه على صفقه بيع سلاح ان لم يكن لها
اثر سلبي محتمل على حقوق الانسان محليا
كما ان الجزء المتعلق بالصين وروسيا مهم
جدا ولابد من اخذه بالاعتبار حيث هناك
تنافس محتدم بين الولايات المتحده وروسيا
ناهيك عن التنافس مع الصين ايضا السيد
روسيا يعني روسيا خلال السنوات الخمس
الماضيه كان لديها حصه في السوق العالمي
فيما يتعلق بالمبيعات العسكريه تقارب
العشرين بالمئه منذ بدايه الحرب في
اوكرانيا باتت هذه الحصه يعني تقل شيئا
فشيئا الان مع هذه التعديلات الجديده هل
ستستفيد الشركات الامريكيه هل ستسمح لها
هذه التعديلات بمزيد من الاستفاده من
الحصه الروسيه ام انها ستشكل عائقا امام
هذه الشركات
اعتقد من الاهميه بمكان القاء نظره على
الاسواق العالميه اولا هناك فكره في
واشنطن وفي اماكن اخرى ان السلاح الروسي
لم يكن اداؤه جيدا خاصه في اوكرانيا
والقدرات الغربيه اثبتت تفوقها لذا لجات
روسيا للضرب بقسوه لتعويض اي نقص لديها في
القدرات التكنولوجيه نحن نعلم ان هذه حرب
طويله لكن الروس يتعلمون من التجربه وسنرى
سرعتهم في التعلم ومن ناحيه الاسواق
العالميه فان ميزانيه الدفاع الامريكيه
ستزداد لتصل الى نحو 880 مليار دولار
الولايات المتحده والاداره في واشنطن يرون
صفقات بيع السلاح على انها اداه مهمه
للشراكه وطريقه فعاله لدعم شركائنا
وحلفائنا لكن ان نظرنا للمساله من زاويه
الاولويات الامريكيه في الاسواق العالميه
سنجد ان على صناعه تلبيه مطالب البنتون
والمطالب القوميه الامريكيه باعاده تعبئه
المخزون الامريكي من السلاح كما نرى
اوروبا تشهد نهضه ضخمه لتطوير قدراتها في
اعقاب العدوان الروسي وهناك منطقه الهادي
الهندي حيث الحلفاء والشركاء يسعون للحصول
على قدرات وكذلك الشرق الاوسط ان كان فيه
فرص فهو السوق العالميه الرابعه وتعد على
درجه من الاهميه
هل الحرب تزيد الفرص لمصنعي سلاح في الغرب
نعم لكن في هذه المرحله المهم هو الطلب
فكل الصناعات الغربيه تتحرك بعجاله لتامين
الذخيره والمركبات العسكريه والمنصات لذلك
سيكون هذا القطاع مثيرا للاهتمام على مدى
السنوات القليله القادمه من حيث معرفه
فائض المخزون الذي يمكن ان يساعد في تلبيه
الطلب على تصدير السلاح وهنا ايضا يمكن ان
نخضع المساله لتحديد الاولويات من حيث من
هو الاكثر للسلاح فهناك دول ما زالت تنتظر
الحصول على القدرات بسبب بعض التحديات في
مجال التزويد الذي زاد تعقيده بعد الحرب
في اوكرانيا
الان على مستوى العالم بات هناك الكثير من
الدول الواعده في مجال الصناعات الدفاعيه
وكذلك هي اكثر انفتاحا على مشاركه
التكنولوجيا بل وحتى تصدير الاسلحه لدول
اخرى لدينا الصين ولدينا كذلك دول اخرى
مثل كوريا الجنوبيه وغيرها برايك هل
التعديلات الجديده فيما يتعلق بهذه
المساله هل راعت هذه المساله وراعت وجود
منافسين للولايات المتحده الان في السوق
العالمي وام انه هذه التعديلات ستشكل عائق
امام الشركات الامريكيه
[موسيقى]
لست متاكدا لكنها تفعل اذ ان اي تعقيد
امام صفقه سلاح من وجهه نظر هذا القطاع
يعد اشكاليا بعض الشيء ومن الناحيه
الثانيه يرى القطاع انه ستكون هناك وفره
في الفرص خاصه في الاسواق المحليه مع
الشركاء والحلفاء ممن ليست لديهم مسائلات
حول حقوق الانسان اعتقد ان اي دوله تشتري
انظمه روسيه وصينيه توجه كذلك رساله
لواشنطن وهي رساله ستهتم بها واشنطن كثيرا
ربما هناك دوله وحيده يمكن ان تحظى
باستثناء هي الهند بسبب اهميتها
الجيوستراتيجيه وهي اكبر دوله في العالم
حاليا وتحظى بثقل يضاه الصين من نواحي عده
رغم استمرارها في شراء السلاح الروسي هناك
ضغط داخل النظام الهندي وخارجه لوقف
التسلح من روسيا لكن الامر المهمه هو ان
المتحده تنظر للمساله بشكل موسع ان كنت
تساعد الاوليجارش الروسي او تحول الاموال
لروسيا او لتجاوز العقوبات عليها اظن ان
هذا يضيف المزيد من التعقيد بالنسبه للدول
التي تود ان تضع لها في كل معسكر قدما
وهذه رساله مهمه لابد من اخذها في
الاعتبار بان الولايات المتحده تنظر للامر
على انها لا تريد ان يستغل نظامها بشكل
ينعكس سلبا عليها وكذلك لا تريد من الدول
التي تزداد تقاربا مع الصين وروسيا ان
تستفيد من القدرات الامريكيه او ان تكون
هذه الدول تساعد دول اخرى تراها امريكا
على انها اشكاليه ومن المثير للاهتمام ان
نرى دول اوروبا تتخذ نهجا مماثلا مع تزايد
قلقهم من روسيا ومن الصين لذلك قد لا يكون
هذا راي واشنطن فقط بل يمكن ان يكون رايا
غربيا موسعا وقد كانت كوريا الجنوبيه
ناجحه جدا بسبب امتلاكها قدرات وفيره لا
يمتلكها مثل قدرات المدفعيات والدبابات
وكذلك القدرات التي عملوا على تطويرها
بذكاء فائق فبالتالي ان الدوله التي
ستستفيد من ذلك بشكل كبير هي كوريا
الجنوبيه
السيد مراديان واشنطن تقول دائما ان
معايير حقوق الانسان هي الاساس برايك هل
ستتاثر الصفقات العسكريه ما بين واشنطن
وتل ابيب بسبب المعايير التي تتحدث عنها
واشنطن خاصه في ظل التقارير الكثيره التي
تتحدث عن الانتهاكات الاسرائيليه لحقوق
الانسان
[موسيقى]
اعتقد ان التحدي تاريخي ومعقد فالولايات
المتحده هي الضامن الامني لاسرائيل في
الشرق الاوسط وكذلك الضامن الامني في
الخليج العربي ومناطق اخرى فيما يتعلق
بعلاقه اداره نتنياهو واشنطن فمن السهل
القول انها متوتره ومن المثير ان نراقب
كيف ستتحول العلاقه بسبب الاحباط الذي
يعانيه المجتمع اليهودي الامريكي من
الحكومه الاسرائيليه اليمينيه التي تزداد
تشددا في القدس هذه العلاقه ستواجه تحديات
عديده واعتقد ان كثرا ينظرون لهذه العلاقه
على انها علاقه نفاق لكن هناك عنصرا مهما
في العلاقه الاسرائيليه الامريكيه وهو
منصوص عليه في القانون بان الولايات
المتحده ملزمه قانونيا بمساعده اسرائيل في
المحافظه على تفوقها العسكري على اعدائها
قد يتغير ذلك او يمكن تعليق صفقات التسلح
ان قرر اعضاء الكونجرس التاخير فليست
الاداره وحدها هي التي توافق على الصفقات
بل على العالم ان يدرك ان اعضاء الكونجرس
وخاصه الشيوخ لديهم الصلاحيه لوقف تنفيذ
الصفقات وكانت امريكا قد اخرت نقل بعض
القدرات لاسرائيل على مدى عقود بسبب عدم
رضاها عما كانت تقوم به الحكومه من المثير
للاهتمام ان نرى كيف سيتم تفسير هذه
السياسه في تلك الحاله علي ان اوضح هنا ان
القلق الاميركي يكون في معرفه ان كان سلاح
الامريكي يتم استخدامه في وضعيه خاطئه
اسرائيل من كبريات الدول المصنعه للسلاح
واي سلاح تقوم بتصنيعه مثل اي سلاح تصنعه
الامارات او اي جهه اخرى يمكن استخدام هذه
الاسلحه بحريه طالما كانت هذه الاسلحه لا
تحتوي على اي عنصر امريكي
رئيس تحرير موقع الدفاع وطيران شكرا جزيلا
على وجودك معنا
[تصفيق]
احدث الدبابات المنضمه لصفوف الجيش الروسي
كان من المفترض ان تدخل الخدمه عام 2018
الا ان هذه الخطط الغيت واعيد احيائها
مؤخرا واستقارير روسيه تفيد بدخولها
الخدمه هذا العام دبابه تي اربعه عشر
هذه الدبابه التي تم تطويرها عام 2013
ظهرت للمره الاولى في عام 2015 خلال عرض
عسكري بمناسبه الذكرى السبعين للنصر في
الحرب العالميه الثانيه الدبابه التي تم
التجربتها في سوريا طبقا لتقارير روسيه
مسلحه بمدفع من عيار 125 مليمتر وبمدى يصل
الى 12 كيلومتر هذه الدبابه يمكنها اطلاق
صواريخ موجهه مضاده للدروع من طراز انفار
او اسبرنتر كما انها مسلحه بمدفع اخر من
عيار 12.7 مليمتر وكذلك مدفع رشاش داخلي
من عيار 7.62 ملم اما برج الدبابه فهو
مزود بمنظومه دفاع نشطه واجهزه استشعار
تمكن الطاقم من رصد التهديدات من اي
صواريخ مضاده للدبابات بل والتعامل معها
الشركه المصنعه لهذه الدبابه تقول انها
مطليه بماده تجعلها خفيه عن اجهزه الرادار
ومنظومات الرؤيه الليليه الحراريه في حين
تتحدث تقارير روسيه عن استلام الجيش
الروسي لسبعه دبابات من هذا الطراز بل
ودخول هذه الدبابات الى ارض المعارك
الدائره حاليا مع الاوكرانيين
بعد الفصل الشركات الاوروبيه تسعى لزياده
حصتها في سوق الصناعات الدفاعيه بالشرق
الاوسط
اهلا بكم من جديد لسنوات ساعه الشركات
الاوروبيه العامله في مجال الصناعات
الدفاعيه لزياده حصتها من سوق الانفاق
الدفاعي حول العالم
منذ اندلاع الحرب في اوكرانيا بات هناك
تزايد كبير في الانفاق الدفاعي سواء هنا
في الشرق الاوسط او حتى في اوروبا لكن الى
اي مدى الشركات الاوروبيه لديها القدره
على التعامل مع تنام الطلب على المنتجات
الدفاعيه ولماذا هناك بعض الدول تفضل
الشركات الامريكيه مقارنه بالشركات
الاوروبيه حول هذا الموضوع معنا السيده
انا كرن مدير عام شركه ساب السويديه في
دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده اولا
السيده انا شكرا على وجودك معنا هنا في
الاستوديو بدايه رئيس التنفيذي لشركه ساب
تحدث مؤخرا عن انه شركه ساب تسعى لزياده
مبيعاتها هنا في الشرق الاوسط وتحدث عن
انه مبيعاتكم فقط 10% من اجمالي مبيعات سب
لماذا هذا الرقم المحدود وكذلك هذا الامر
هل له علاقه بالقدرات التصنيعيه لشركه ساب
ام بسياسات محدده تفرضها الحكومه في
السويد
بدايه اشكركم على الاستضافه من دواعي
سروري ان اكون معكم بالحديث عن سبب فنحن
شركه سويديه واصبحنا شركه عالميه لكننا
بجذور سويديه والسوق الام لشركتنا كانت
السوق السويديه على مدى سنوات عديده اما
حاليا وكجزء من استراتيجيه ساب اصبحنا
نسعى لاستكشاف اسواق جديده عالميا لخدمه
مصالح الشركه والشرق الاوسط واحد من هذه
الاسواق التي نسعى لزياده التركيز عليها
ولذلك اشار المدير التنفيذي لساب الى ان
الشرق الاوسط احد مراكز اهتمام الشركه
لدينا وجود رسمي في الامارات وفي دول اخرى
في المنطقه لكننا نامل ان نحقق المزيد من
التوسعاده فيما يتعلق بالخطه التي تعملون
عليها لزياده مبيعاتكم هنا في الشرق
الاوسط ما هي تفاصيل او ملامح هذه الخطه
صعب
فقد كان حضور النشط في المنطقه منذ
ثمانينيات من خلال بيع منتجاتنا ونعمل
حاليا على زياده حضورنا وهذه خطوه حكيمه
وبوسعنا هنا التحدث عن الامارات كمثال اذ
بدانا بمكتب تمثيل لمجموعه من مسؤول
المبيعات في ابوظبي ومن ثم كانت الخطوه
التاليه عبر اقامه شركه مع شريك اماراتي
محلي وقبل سنوات اتخذنا خطوه اضافيه
بافتتاح شركه اجنبيه على ارض الامارات
نقوم من خلالها بالاعمال الهندسيه وتطوير
المنتجات وتجهيز المصانع واعدادها ومن ثم
تقديم الدعم على المستوى الاقليمي كما ان
المنتجات التي نقوم بتطويرها هنا هي جزء
من المحفظه الكامله لساب وكذلك على صعيد
السوق العالميه هذه واحد من الطرق التي
نتبعها لتوسيعتها حصتنا من السوق
الاقليميه الى جانب حصتنا في السوق فنحن
نسعى للتقارب مع القطاع الاكاديمي واقامه
علاقات شراكه مع شركات في المنطقه ولتحقيق
ذلك بنجاح نحتاج لوجود شركه ثابته لنا في
المنطقه هذه هي حقيقه استراتيجيتنا من اجل
زياده حصتنا في اسواق الشرق الاوسط
هل تركزون في هذه المرحله على تسويق
منتجات فقط ام انكم كذلك تسعون الى مساله
شراكه مع دول منطقه الشرق الاوسط لانه
لدينا الان في منطقه الشرق الاوسط الكثير
من الدول التي لا تسعى فقط لمجرد مبيعات
ولكن كذلك تسعى لتاسيس صناعات دفاعيه خاصه
بها اذا طلب من ساب المشاركه في مساله نقل
التكنولوجيا ونقل الافكار هل توافقون
ولديكم استراتيجيه تتماشى مع رؤيه هذه
الدول في هذا المنطق
نعم لدينا استراتيجيه خاصه لذلك وهي قائمه
على ان نقل المعرفه التكنولوجي السريه هو
امر يشكل جزءا من سياده الدول بغض النظر
عن الدوله التي نمثلها وبالتالي اعمل على
حمايتها
استراتيجيتنا هنا في الشرق الاوسط هي
البدء في بناء هذه المعرفه وبالطبع حسب
اسلوب ساب بتنفيذ اعمالها سواء العمليات
الاجرائيه او القوالب المعده مسبقا اي
طريقه انجازنا لاعمالنا بشكل عام فنحن نرى
اننا تعلمنا علما اننا ناتي من دوله صغيره
بميزانيه محدوده حيث ان السويد دوله صغيره
نسبيا بتعداد سكان عشره ملايين تعلمنا ان
نعمل بذكاء وكذلك بكفاءه عاليه ناهيك عن
مساله التعاون مع شركاء اخرين سواء
الشركات الحكوميه العامله في هذا القطاع
او المؤسسات الاكاديميه وهذا نراه ايضا
احد النجاح لكن الاساس هو اقامه الشركه
هنا ومن ثم استقطاب الموارد البشريه
المناسبه والاصول اللازمه واخيرا تطبيق
طرق عملنا هنا وبالنظر لمجمل اعمالنا نحن
في النهايه لا نريد ان نتنافس مع انفسنا
عالميا بل نراعي ان تكون المنتجات التي
نطورها هنا متناسبه مع المحفظه العالميه
الكامله لمنتجات الشركه هذه هي حقيقه
استراتيجيتنا
منذ بدايه الصراع في اوكرانيا بات هناك
تنامي كبير في الطلب على المنتجات
الدفاعيه سواء هنا في الشرق الاوسط او حتى
في اوروبا وكذلك على مستوى العالم لكن
يعني الملاحظه طبقا للتقارير التي صدرت
مؤخرا بانه هناك زياده في الطلب على
المنتجات الدفاعيه من الشركات الاوروبيه
الامريكيه مقارنه بالشركات الاوروبيه
لماذا هذا الامر
بدايه علي القول ان الحرب هي كارثه بحق
الانسانيه والرؤيه الخاصه لسبب هي حق
الانسان في الشعور بامان وعندما نرى اي
نزاعات مثل تلك الحرب القريبه من بلادنا
بين اوكرانيا وروسيا فهي بمثابه تاكيد على
حق الامم في ان تكون قادره على ان تدافع
عن نفسها وتحقيق الاستقرار والسلام وهذه
مسائل اساسيه ومحوريه لتحقيق الاستدام
البيئيه الى جانب امور كثيره اخرى مهمه
للبشريه والان ونحن نواجه هذا الوضع
الجيوسي الذي يكتنفه الغموض ليس اوروبيا
فقط بل عالميا ايضا لهذا نرى هذا الطلب
المتزايد ليس من امريكا فقط بل من
الاوروبيين كذلك وكثير من الدول رفعت
ميزانيتها الدفاعيه نعم نحن نشهد زياده في
الطلب بشكل عام وما نقوم به في ساب هو رفع
قدراتنا التصنيعيه لتلبيه الطلب سيده
انا كريم مدير عام شركه ساب السويديه في
دوله الامارات العربيه المتحده شكرا على
وجودك معنا
[تصفيق]
لا يكتمل تجهيز افراد المشاه دون سلاح
يمنح الجندي القدره على ايقاع الخسائر
واحداث الصدمه في صفوف العدو هذا اما
تمهيدا لهجوم او لانسحاب ولهذا كانت
القنبله اليدويه القنبله اليدويه هي
السلاح طاغى على ساحات القتال منذ الحرب
العالميه الاولى كما كان لها دور بارز في
حسم الالاف من المواجهات القريبه
الاستخدام الاول للقنابل اليدويه بدا في
القرن الحادي عشر في الصين حينها كان يعبئ
البارود في وعاء من السيراميك مزود بفتيل
ويقوم الجندي باشعاله والقائه على الطرف
الاخر ومع الحاجه الى تطوير سلاح فعال
قادر على الحاق الضرر في صفوف الجنود
القابعين في الخنادق نجح البريطانيون في
عام 1908 في تصنيع ما يعرف بالقنبله
اليدويه رقم واحد الا ان هذه القنبله لم
تكن امنه بشكل كاف الجندي المستخدم لها
لكن في العام 1915 نجح المخترع البريطاني
واليملت في صناعه اول قنبله يدويه قريبه
لشكلها الذي نعرفه الان الحرب العالميه
الثانيه فتحت الباب امام تطوير القنابل
اليدويه كان اشهر تصميم هو تصميما لقنبله
المانيه كانت تشبه شكل المطرقه لاحقا تم
انتاج قنابل يدويه حديثه متعدده المهام
منها قنابل مضاده للافراد واخرى مضاده
للاليات وكذلك قنابل اخرى صوتيه لمهام
الاقتحام واخرى دخانيه او تحتوي على غاز
مسيل للدموع
حلقه عسكريه لهذا الاسبوع قد انتهت
الاسبوع المقبل المزيد من الاسلحه والمزيد
من الصفقات في امان الله
[موسيقى]